and now here are the nominees for best
animated short film - Sara
Daria Keshava hair loves Matthew a
cherry and Karen Rupert Tolliver
kit bull Roseanna Sullivan and Catherine
Hendrickson
memorable bruno coulais
there's only place long before sister
such eat some and the Oscar goes to
hello
this is the first Oscar and nomination
for Matthew a cherry and Karen Rupert
Oliver
[Applause]
thank you so much to the Academy and
everybody out there that supported this
film there were lots of you we share
this award with you there were so many
filmmakers that worked so hard on this
and it was a labor of love and it was
because we have a firm belief that
representation matters deeply especially
especially in cartoons because in
cartoons that's when we first see our
movies and it's how I should we shape
our lives and think about how we see the
world so I want to thank the Sony
Pictures animation who were the
progressive people that believed in us
from the beginning Christine Belson
Jeff korchek thank you to Lyon Forge
animation to six point harness and to
Matthew cherry thank you to my my
beautiful husband my son chase and miles
for believing in me thank you so much so
we have a big team that we have to thank
but time is running short so I just want
to say that hair love was done because
we wanted to see more representation and
animation we wanted to normalize black
hair there's a very important issue
that's out there is the crown act and if
we can help to get this passing off at
these states will help stories like the
Andre Arnold's who's our special guest
tonight stop to happen this award is
dedicated to Kobe Bryant may we all have
a second act as great as his West thank
you
[Applause]